I was speaking with Lee Bollinger about
coming to columbia he was I I'm a New
Yorker he brought out to Michigan where
they had more land than I ever thought I
could imagine and he was saying that
Columbia was out of space and being
someone who had from New York I kind of
understood that but I truly didn't
understand the acute real effect the
lack of space was having on the
university sense of its future and that
has to do with whether we could attract
and retain the best researchers to do to
do science but it also had two students
competing for every closet the senior
it's embarrassing to say the senior
leadership of the university not
including the president when I first got
here would meet every two weeks to
assign each closet that had become free
on the campus this is really an
extraordinary inflection point we have
as much space as the first McKim Mead
and white master plan for this campus we
are moving forward with mine brain
behavior we have the best neuroscience
Department in the world and that is
going to be a pivotal point in our
growth of science on the campus we're in
the process now of doing architect
selection for a Columbia Business School
a very important move for one of the
jewels in our in the university's crown
we're going to have the School of the
Arts 120 fifth Street as Joe has said we
have felt the pressure move from trying
to persuade people it was actually going
to happen to everyone saying to us make
it happen faster and the goal here
candidly is to turn Columbia back into a
typical University at a typical
University when there's a compelling
intellectual agenda and there's money
you could build the facilities to
explore that agenda at Columbia we had
neither the money nor the space to do
that the space is now available Susan's
working very very hard to find the
financial resources and we as a typical
great research university can now pursue
our future so it's very exciting moment
that will frankly unfold over the next
generation or so
Susan what's happening at the University
from your perspective that's not yet in
the headlines so one of the things that
I'll I had a couple of things I want to
show you so I this may not be totally
responsive to Robert but I wanted to
show this to it as a politician who
makes sure she gets her points across
we've already discussed who as the
leverage in this relationship and I had
hoped on there I'm happy to tell you
know it's been a very obviously a very
difficult year from the development
perspective because of the economic
situation although we have fared this
period remarkably well because so many
alumni and friends had already made us a
philanthropic priority and I'm happy to
say the university campaign to raise
four billion dollars by the end of
calendar 2011 continues to be ahead of
schedule and we raised almost 400
million new pledges and gifts in fiscal
year 09 toward that goal so that was
that was a good thing I had hoped there
might be a big new gift that I could
give you advance word about stay tuned
I'm hoping that that that we'll be able
to talk about that soon and while I'm
well I have the microphone I'm just
going to keep it for a second let's go
right ahead so I in case you hadn't seen
it we talked about the ribbon cutting
for the Alumni Center and we had a
couple of photos Lee Bollinger and Bill
Campbell some University Trustees Jeff
Colvin the head of the College Alumni
Association who's here this morning and
is doing a program along with Michelle
moody Adams the new dean of the college
that was a great moment and we did
actually cut the ribbon and there was a
little suspense it was a great day
finally up in terms of what things that
have changed athletics you know when Lee
Bollinger came came back to Colombia you
know he had worked so hard at Michigan
not to let athletics get over you know
important he did not like the fact that
Columbia was at the bottom when you know
you looked at performance his view is if
we're gonna if we're going to have
athletics then we should be we should
strive to be as good in athletics as we
are at everything else that we try to do
diane murphy came in she's just finished
her fifth year as athletic director
a lot of wonderful things have happened
and she gave this report to the October
Trustees meeting where she showed this
chart and then so this is ivy total Ivy
championships from 93 94 to 2003-4 so
over a 10-year period and then you look
at what's happened since 2004-2005 we're
now in the middle of the pack and real
progress on that front and we still have
a long way to go I actually I have a few
extra tickets to the Harvard game if
anybody wants to duck out on the session
I won't tell if anybody must go
seriously i have a few in my purse so
anyway that's a great i think that's a
great columbia story too and one that's
still unfolding